[Music]
hawaii is one of the remote places on
the planet
and in the open ocean there are no
landmarks
so hawaii was discovered by canoes with
no gps no motors no electronics
uh just pure nature and that's what
we're uh so we're doing today to
celebrate that
[Music]
so around hokulea
she is a replica of a
polynesian voyaging canoe
they were
the mode of transportation for
discovering the hawaiian islands
there's no metal there's no screws
there's no nails there's no braces that
hold the canoe together it's nothing but
lashings a rope
there's no motors on board there's no
navigation equipment that we use to go
across the ocean
we started in hawaii in end of may 2014
we embarked on this worldwide voyage
which first ended up going towards
tahiti through our ancestral routes and
now we're here in martha's vineyard
a big part of this voyage right malama
honua is to train a whole cadre
of young navigators and captains
wait don't leave the back sail let's get
the uh the 23 out
a big force here
[Music]
khalil wong
is one of the apprentice navigators i've
done four voyages with him
and he was on his own across the
atlantic ocean and he was brilliant i
mean he was just so successful you know
after traveling like 1200 miles finding
just little islands in the middle of
nowhere you're talking like thousands of
hours
of observation at sea
when we're navigating the open ocean our
biggest clue that tells us where we are
and where we're going is the sun the sun
as we know rises in the east and sets in
the west so if we just know where one
point of is then we know where
everything else is
the stars do us the same thing it's like
the compass in the sky we memorize close
to 200 stars and know where they rise
and where they set and how they move
across the skies
the sun and the stars and everything
work in conjunction with the swells
so in the absence of the sun
then you maintain the orientation of the
crew to those small patterns that's a
very difficult thing
[Music]
the ukulele was built with the express
purpose of proving that navigation by
the ancient way was very viable these
canoes could be guided over 2 000 miles
in long distances
they proved that on their very first
voyage in 1976.
what it means is continuation kaleo and
these others they're just like a pinch
of salt as far as the people who know
how to do this type of navigation
[Music]
imagine you're a sailor
working on a great lakes freighter for
two months at a time
and you need your mail delivered
well
that's where we come in
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is jim hogan and i'm the owner
and the fourth generation of the jw
westcott company this company was
started in 1874 by my great grandfather
captain john ward westcott
we operate a
shorter ship and ship to shore delivery
boat in the port of detroit we're the
only floating zip code in actually the
united states and it still holds true
today
any package that's got that 48222 zip
code is going to arrive here at our
station
on any given day we receive the mail and
packages in the morning you see the
various pigeon holes as they were called
each of those represent different ships
we place mail in those slots and we wait
until the vessel is actually coming
through the port of detroit
hey dorothy how are you doing today
pretty good how about yourself not too
bad just getting finished up here okay
real good let's see a little bit
we packed the
mailbags the captain takes the vessel
away from our dock
and off the midstream we go
we deliver mail by the pail and that's
the sailor's mailbox if you will the
crewmen aboard the ship we'll lower down
a bucket and we'll fill the bucket with
the mail
and then we send the bucket back up
sometimes we're delivering passengers
crew
we had a grocery order a number of years
ago the last item was about three and a
half feet long and i looked at it it was
a tuna a whole tuna
we end the delivery with a salute
we head back to the dock we wait for our
next adventure
i've worked here for 43 years i'm
grateful to have been a part of all of
this and i look forward to a fifth
generation taking this on
and
seeing where it goes
up or down the river as it were
[Music]
[Music]
ships are magnificent creatures of the
sea built designed for the deep waters
of the ocean
but once you bring these magnificent
creatures to inland waters around the
world
they get fairly clumpy
the ship at sea may travel 3000 miles in
a straight line
but the difficulty happens when you get
to port and that's when a ship pilot
takes over
[Music]
he's essentially like a valet who parks
your car the pilot comes out usually on
a small pilot boat and then they climb
up the side of the ship on a small
ladder
up to the wheelhouse to get the ship
into the port
if it floats we are capable of moving it
here at mpi we train ship pilots to
guide the largest moving objects on the
planet
we have traditional classroom training
we have a state-of-the-art ship
simulator
and then we have
manned model
[Music]
although these models may look like toy
boats they're actually precise tools
used to mimic the behavior of vessels
[Music]
if you took a full-size vessel and
shrunk it down 25 times you can get very
reliable results
a human being on our models would be
like an inch and three quarters tall
the man models are between twenty four
thousand and thirty thousand pounds of
weight and they have point four
horsepower they behave exactly like a
ship
this is real this is how it's done on
board all the ships around the world
starboard 10 degrees
we surely would not want to practice
with a perfectly good ship
and say well captain we have to drop
anchors and simulate broke down engines
and steering so we do that with these
vessels
it's a profession that i think for me at
the top of the marathon field
it's an awesome responsibility
and very challenging
when i finish and walk down the dock
look back at the ship and say yes
that was a
good challenge
fair
video
[Music]
at only 24 years old geraxude is aboard
a 30-foot boat sailing around the world
completely on his own
[Music]
[Music]
he left his home in france two and a
half years ago to begin his journey
[Music]
you know
[Music]
[Music]
although he's been navigating alone he's
found an unlikely companion
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's journey takes us to the dutch
town of geethorn
is just like any normal town with one
exception
roads they don't have them
the manchester san andreas way is open
boat
someone's gonna develop
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one of the town's resident boat builders
he's known for punters a flat bottom
boat that originated in guitor it is
and where there are boats there are
bridges
167 to be exact and just like any town
people need their groceries their
furniture their beer you name it
but in guitar they must pass through
anton he's the town's bridge guard
[Music]
look at that
one of those boats is the fire boat
this is bart and eric holden
field warning
[Music]
and this is jan he's in charge of
maintaining the natural lands around
geethorn
[Music]
so there you have it the residents of
keethorn prove that a life without
asphalt traffic and trips to the dmv can
be pretty damn great
rhodes who needs them
bye geethorn
[Music]